quiero compartir con ustedes que desde
hace muchos años tanto por mis
experiencias personales como por mis
experiencias profesionales pude advertir
que había personas con algunas áreas de
su existencia
verdaderamente luminosas que eran
ejemplo que eran inspiradoras que
sobresalían pero no obstante esas mismas
personas tenían esto en su actuar
cotidiano
áreas definitivamente descuidadas
si no es que sombrías
y yo me preguntaba cuando uno tiene el
ánimo de crecer
si yo mismo no tendría algunas partes de
mi actuar cotidiano que estuviesen
descuidadas
cuando quiere uno llegar a ser una
persona integral debe de cuidar todos
los aspectos de la vida cotidiana
últimamente los medios de comunicación
nos han dado cuenta de muchos casos en
donde personajes que admirábamos tanto
por ciertas partes de su vida
ahora resulta que tenían
partes de la misma verdaderamente
sombríos déjenme ponerles un ejemplo
en los primeros décadas del siglo 20
un escritor francés llamado louis
ferdinand augustus conocido por su
seudónimo
céline
modifico la literatura francesa
con las novelas que público
con su método realista directo
podríamos decir hasta crudo conmoción no
muchas conciencias
pues bien teniendo estas dos áreas tan
luminosas de su actuación porque
adicionalmente era médico y el ejercicio
de su profesión lo dedicaba a atender a
los menesterosos a los menos favorecidos
era de estos médicos que reciben por sus
servicios profesionales algunos
vegetales o algún animalito
e insisto teniendo estas dos áreas tan
luminosas de su actuación era
profundamente nazista
y escribió
los peores panfletos los más terribles
panfletos en contra del pueblo judío
hace algunos años alguna entidad de
literatura francesa pretendió hacerle un
homenaje exclusivamente por sus méritos
como literato muchas voces se levantaron
para oponerse a ese homenaje que no se
llevó a cabo
qué difícil es juzgar a una persona
cuando tiene áreas tan luminosas de su
vida de su actuación y en cambio otras
verdaderamente sombrías pensando en esto
yo me preguntaba cuáles serían las áreas
que en mi caso debiera de cuidar para
tratar de hacerlas crecer todas en la
medida de mis posibilidades
y lograr llegar así a constituir me en
una persona integral estuve caminando en
ese sentido y encontré para mí que eran
siete áreas en estas siete áreas
pensé que incluía la actividad completa
de mi existencia los más importantes
aspectos de la vida y les comento en el
área afectiva con lo que mis relaciones
con todas las personas cercanas con
todos mis seres queridos con mis amigos
con mis familiares con mis vecinos con
mis compañeros de trabajo o con todos
aquellos con quienes tiene uno trato sea
frecuente o sea ocasional y esa relación
que tiene uno que entablar con ellos
tiene que estar basada por supuesto en
el respeto en el afecto en el apoyo en
tratar de satisfacer las hambres que
todos los seres humanos tenemos de
tiempo caricias y reconocimiento esto no
se da automáticamente se tiene que
construir se tiene que trabajar en ello
todos tenemos cerca de nosotros a
personas que en ocasiones son difíciles
y respecto de las cuales en el trato con
ellas hay que hacer un esfuerzo un
esfuerzo a veces de aceptación y
definitivamente un esfuerzo de empatía
de ponernos en su lugar para poder
apreciar cómo estas personas ven al
mundo en fin esta es una potencialidad
que tenemos que hacer crecer mediante un
esfuerzo la siguiente potencialidad que
yo definí para mí era la de la
inteligencia la inteligencia que ha sido
normalmente identificada con el concepto
que ahora sabemos esa inteligencia
racional es decir esa capacidad que
tenemos de tomar los datos de la
realidad llegar a conclusiones y con eso
navegar en la vida
desde la década de los 80 un estudioso
del crecimiento de la inteligencia
humana gardner nos dio el conocimiento
de que las inteligencias serán múltiples
primero nos definió siete inteligencias
posteriormente se incrementaron a diez y
luego hay autores que dicen que son
muchas más
por ejemplo la inteligencia
interpersonal esa que nos permite la
autocrítica ya en nuestro tiempo se ha
hecho común el término de la
inteligencia emocional otra de las
inteligencias o una más que es
verdaderamente trascendente que es la
inteligencia espiritual estas
inteligencias igualmente requieren un
crecimiento requieren que nos aboquemos
todo el tiempo a tratar de hacerla
crecer la siguiente potencialidad la del
trabajo
todos sabemos que el trabajo dignifica
al hombre y sea cual fuere la razón por
la que nos toca hacer un determinado
trabajo sea por circunstancia sea por
necesidad o mejor aún si es por vocación
tenemos que hacerlo de la mejor manera
posible porque eso además de dignificar
nos nos da una autoestima ante nosotros
y ante los demás y permite incluso es el
medio para permitir que no sólo tengamos
una remuneración sino que podamos servir
a los demás así es que a lo que nos
dediquemos tenemos que hacerlo a nivel
de excelencia
esta área siguiente aprendizaje y
enseñanza me pareció que era importante
porque somos la única especie que nace
de una manera pero puede morir de otra
nacemos hombres pero podemos morir seres
humanos nos convertimos en seres humanos
si nos sobreponemos a nosotros mismos si
logramos sobreponernos a nuestros
instintos y entonces accedemos a la
calidad de seres humanos pero para
llegar a ser seres humanos tenemos que
aprender de los demás es la única manera
y cuando aprendemos de los otros
adquirimos el ineludible compromiso de
enseñar a los que vienen de atrás por
eso me pareció que era una potencialidad
muy importante
el cuidado físico todos sabemos que
nuestro organismo es una maquinaria
perfecta que se autorregula que ese auto
renueva cada siete años todos nuestros
órganos están renovados y sin embargo
seguimos siendo los mismos
ahora que el movimiento integral llegó a
la medicina
sabemos de los cinco pilares de la
medicina de la nutrición el sueño el
ejercicio el manejo del estrés y los
afectos todos tenemos un potencial de
salud depende de nosotros cuánto tiempo
durará ese potencial la siguiente área
de crecimiento es el área espiritual
y ya decíamos también es una
inteligencia y esto es lo que nos lleva
a tratar de conectarnos con lo
trascendente con el origen y destino de
nosotros mismos con el sentido de la
vida hay algunas personas que buscan a
través de una religión su crecimiento
espiritual está bien habemos otros que
buscamos el crecimiento espiritual a
través de la reflexión de la
contemplación del diálogo del
aprendizaje sea como fuere con por uno u
otro camino
lo importante es orientarnos hacia el
bien hacia lo sublime hacia lo noble una
posibilidad más de crecimiento
finalmente el área política o de
compromiso social esta es la parte en
donde nosotros nos comprometemos con las
mejores causas de la humanidad
con los que sufren hambre con los que
sufren los que están padeciendo en
venezuela con nuestros compatriotas que
sufren inseguridad a toda la miseria en
áfrica o la guerra en siria o la
contaminación de los mares o el cambio
climático o la ecología
o el desequilibrio económico en el mundo
esto nos requiere de un compromiso y de
una participación de una solidaridad
estás como pueden ver ustedes son las
siete áreas que yo definí para mí para
tratar de en la medida de mis
posibilidades hacerlas crecer para
tratar de llegar a ser un ser humano
integral
al mejor ustedes están pensando cuáles
son las áreas que creen ustedes que
debieran desarrollar para llegar a la
integralidad a lo mejor son estas a lo
mejor estas son pocas o son muchas o son
estas pero con diferente contenido no se
trata de que en el cuidado de nuestro
físico lleguemos a hacer campeones
olímpicos ni que en el desarrollo de
nuestra inteligencia podamos superar la
ley de la relatividad o que en el
crecimiento espiritual podamos tener en
la bondad de la madre teresa de calcuta
se trata del concepto lo importante es
el concepto el concepto que genere la
actitud de que no dejemos ningún área de
nuestro ser descuidada
en estas reflexiones me encontraba
cuando alguna visita a la librería
un texto me llamó poderosamente la
atención porque en su título concentraba
dos de los conceptos que más me
interesan el libro se llama
espiritualidad integral quien lo escribe
es el doctor ken wilber ken wilber es un
psicólogo verdaderamente impresionante
es uno de los líderes de la cuarta
escuela de psicología la psicología
transpersonal y es uno de los pioneros
del movimiento integral y el doctor
wilbert tiene una vasta obra y en
algunos de los libros que leí de él que
se llama visión integral descubrí que el
doctor wilbert nos plantea a los
lectores una práctica para ser seres
humanos integrales
imagínense la sorpresa que tuve cuando
alguien que se ha dicho
bill clinton dijo de ken wilber que tal
mente más brillante de nuestro tiempo
planteaba en su libro visión integral
una matriz de práctica vital integral y
el doctor wilbert nos decía son nueve
las áreas que hay que desarrollar
yo de manera empírica había llegado a
siete el doctor wilbert nos dice nueve
solo que el doctor will ven la
diferencia y dice hay cuatro esenciales
y cinco auxiliares les ruego que solo
nos fijemos en la nominación de cada
módulo porque la información en ese
cuadro como ven ustedes es muy vasta
pero está disponible en internet
y me dio mucho gusto que yo coincidía
con el doctor wilbert en tres de los
módulos esenciales en cuerpo mente y
espíritu pero el doctor wilber agregaba
aquí una respecto de la cual yo no tenía
ni la menor idea que era en el año 2007
cuando estaba lo yo leyendo este libro
doctor wilbert decía hay una área un
módulo esencial que se llama sombra
me puse a estudiar qué es la sombra y
averigüe qué es un concepto acuñado por
el psicólogo hyung carl gustav jung
qué consiste en que desde que el ser
humano tiene consciencia empieza a
acumular a reunir todas las experiencias
que le son negativas las traumáticas las
dolorosas las vergonzosas pero por serlo
no las quiere ver y las oculta y las
lleva atrás de él y trata de olvidarlas
y no voltear nunca a verlas pero esa
sombra puede crecer tanto que arruine la
vida entera de la persona y no sólo eso
sino de que se proyecte hacia los demás
haciendo miserable la existencia de las
gentes que están alrededor
y el doctor wilbert además dice que hay
cinco módulos auxiliares nuevamente
coincidía yo con el doctor wilber en dos
de ellos en este trabajo tienes las
relaciones pero pero agregaba tres
módulos auxiliares el de en la la ética
el sexo y las emociones
el doctor wilbert nos dice que si
desarrollamos los cinco módulos
auxiliares podremos lograr que nuestros
cuatro módulos esenciales sean plenos y
con esto la persona será una persona
integral
nos presenta también el doctor wilber en
esta obra espiritualidad integral un
mapa completo de las mentes más
brillantes de nuestro tiempo que se han
dedicado al estudio del crecimiento
humano en términos de su desarrollo
cognitivo o de los estadios de la fe o
de los valores o de la visión del mundo
pero todos coinciden en que hay
fundamentalmente tres grados de
crecimiento el primero desde que nacemos
que los hombres no nacemos ni buenos ni
malos sino nacemos egoístas
así es que el primer grado
de crecimiento está está dominado por el
egoísmo
si la persona logra crecer y llegar al
segundo grado estará dominado por el
concepto nosotros el egoísmo se reduce y
surge la solidaridad y la identidad con
los demás y si aún logramos crecer al
tercer grado este tercer grado está
dominado por el concepto todos nosotros
es decir surge la posibilidad de
hacernos uno con el universo déjenme
resaltar dos de los elementos
fundamentales del doctor wilbert uno el
que tienen ustedes del lado izquierdo es
el crecimiento de los niveles de
conciencia y el otro el que tienen
ustedes del lado derecho es el
crecimiento de los estados de conciencia
me refiero a los estados de conciencia
porque datan de muchos más años
en los estados de conciencia ha habido
personas que han logrado el quinto
estado de conciencia es decir su máximo
estado desde hace cincuenta mil años los
tres primeros son muy comunes para todos
nosotros es vigilia como nos encontramos
ahora sueño y sueño profundo pero el
cuarto estado de conciencia implica ya
el reconocimiento de nuestra verdadera
esencia y el quinto estado es el
despertar es la iluminación esa que
encontró siddharta o sea diamond y al
pie de la higuera cuando encontró las
cuatro nobles verdades y que para salir
del samsara y llegar al nirvana había
que seguir el camino óctuple cuando
logró esos yamuni que logró el turingia
tita que en él se en japonés se llama
sartori o en el catolicismo se llama la
paz de cristo obtuvo la absoluta
libertad
la absoluta libertad es decir el
desapego respecto de todos los
sufrimientos que los hombres podemos
tener
en cambio los niveles de conciencia la
línea que tienen ustedes del lado
izquierdo es un conocimiento que tenemos
apenas hace 100 años y del lado
izquierdo anoté las referencias de cómo
la humanidad ha ido logrando el
crecimiento de los niveles de conciencia
como ustedes ven ahí de la prehistoria a
220 mil años antes de cristo la
humanidad se encontraba en el arca dico
es decir en el nivel de conciencia
dominado por los instintos
les pongo por ejemplo el pluralismo que
se da en la década de los 60 del siglo
20 cuando toda la humanidad se orienta
hace una mejor comprensión
déjenme concluir con la siguiente
invitación
los seres humanos somos lo más
evolucionado del universo conocido
como dijo carl sagan somos la forma en
que el universo se piensa a sí mismo
por ello aprovechar el conocimiento que
hemos logrado de la evolución del
universo
y lograr el crecimiento de nuestra
conciencia a los mayores niveles nos
permitiría colocarnos en la punta de lo
más evolucionado que existe como dijo
martin heidegger el ser humano es una
potencialidad lanzada al universo
hagamos que esa potencialidad sea una
realidad maravillosa muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]